welcome the campaigns the different
campaigns for the European elections are
in full swing and we are here at the
last plenary session of this particular
European Parliament because there will
be a new one come May and that is being
noticed outside of the European Union as
well that's why we will discuss today
EU elections why they matter to Africa
and that's an outcome of those elections
that will be closely monitored in Africa
this is a continent that has after all
shared a long and complex relationship
with Europe so stick with us and our
guests we have a great panel here to my
right over there Marvin ah who is a
member of snd basically social
democratic faction in the European
Parliament by the way all Africa experts
here on the panel and Murray says it is
time to rebuild a new partnership
between the EU and Africa turning the
pages of the past and to my left we are
joined by Bienvenue Angua she is a
managing director of German African SME
alliances connect small and medium
enterprises in Germany and Africa and
she says that it's time for the SMEs to
enter the Africa market for long term
investment
and on an eye-level mission gala over to
my left a member of the biggest party of
the European Parliament the conservative
EPP likely to remain the biggest party
also in the European Parliament and he
says Africa needs Europe to set clear
political priorities to face common
challenges to the benefit of both and
last but not least we're joined by dr.
Tico uma Radha
he is the director general for this
small and medium enterprises agency of
Nigeria and he says that the EU should
do more on good governance in Africa by
stopping corrupt money getting to Europe
from Africa he also adds that we should
treat Africa as equal partners in trade
so you can tell we have a lot of
different experts here also on small to
medium enterprises and there's a reason
for that because of course one of the
main topics between Africa and the
European Union is trade and there are
different reasons they go way back why
this is complicated
we tried to
get down for you prepare a vast and
diverse continent home to some 1.3
billion people Africa has massive
potential coffee cotton and vital
Natural Resources Africa has a lot to
offer it has the world's youngest
population Africa's potential seems
boundless its biggest trading partners
economy is still on the debit side why
and how much does this have to do with
Europe free trade is a centerpiece of EU
policy Africa gets access to the
European market but needs to open its
markets for European products and often
can't compete officially the EU now
advocates an equal partnership it has
been customary for too long for
Europeans to lecture Africans that's
over don't want charity they want
regional value chains and jobs noting
Africa should be able to transform these
raw materials and to provide labor for
youth Asian free trade is the EU robbing
Africa of its future
and that's the question where we're
going to pick up and I want to throw
that question to you dr. Rida we've
heard that Africa has massive potential
but is there a you robbing Africa of its
future through free trade no we have to
look at it in many ways first of all we
must recognize the fact that EU has been
a very strong partner to Africa and this
has dated back since you are in the
colonial time and we need to deepen that
kind of relationship but now you think
it did more harm or more good no I think
we need to do it in a mutual agreement
so that Africa will be able to benefit
from it what I'm saying in essence is
Africa is an exporter of largely oil and
gas to Europe but we are major importers
or primary Goods the primary goods
should be produced in Africa a primary
goods should be produced in Africa
companies European companies hosta
established in Africa to utilize the raw
materials available in Africa so that
there will be creation of jobs for our
teeming youth and there will be also
equal opportunity in terms of the
economic development and prosperity of
our people in Africa mr. Rana why
doesn't you do that I mean we hear a lot
that the EU wants to do this but if you
look at the legislation it always seems
to favor European companies exactly
because Europe is working for Europe and
they don't care about something else
than Europe so it's necessary to have
with us African people African civil
society African elected people make
making advocacy for having more for
Africa and you feel like you're doing
enough in that sense yeah I think it's
not enough for the moment because we are
dealing with epass European partnership
agreements from the past and from the
past is just guaranteeing that Europe is
having raw materials and Europe is
entering the market of Africa and I
think this is a mistake we have to have
a win-win situation and African people
needs to have development with trade
agreements and this is what we have to
discuss with African people for the new
new partnership and not only economic
partnership but new partnership with
Africa
so Bienvenue do you feel that this has
happening you know Marie is saying that
the old model is outdated do we have
something new and is it working
I mean the the question of the fairness
of the Free Trade Agreement is very
central and very important and when we
consider the evolution of the Free Trade
Agreement in now I can say that we are
in a good way actually with also the
e-pass as it was mentioned because I
think that there is two central
principles which are very important
first of all this reciprocity because
it's enabled it will be it will enable
the ACPs country also to largely export
their goods without any thing any duties
and also any quarters it is something
that it is also not large the second one
it is this question of sustainability
because if you think about the free
trade agreement of a cotton you it would
be the end on 2020 and if you have
something sustainable and don't have a
limit
it also can promote investment and
people can say okay I will rethink in
long term investment and it can also
bring some investment is it is at the
end what we'd want to have more
investment that create more jobs in
within the continent well the European
Commission is certainly thinking about
sustainability saying that the focus
between eua relations is shifting
towards knowledge sharing and
responsible investment can you give me
examples where you feel this is working
so yes I mean this this know-how
transfer is a very key features and for
instance I'm here representing the BMW
our association and we also speak a lot
with our members and the SMEs and the
the vocal vocational training and now a
transfer is the key the key things that
they wanted to give as investment to to
African countries I'd like to put that
over to mr. gala you've been to many
African countries you know the continent
from
European perspective when we hear all
this it all sounds very nice all these
initiatives it's a little complicated
but isn't it the case that most people
on the ground in the African countries
you visited don't really experience all
that well first of all I think if we
look at the point of departure trade
wise we have these existing schemes as
the economic partnership agreements and
the EBA the everything but arms
initiative for 32 of the least developed
countries which offer duty and quota
free access to our markets that is only
the one side I think indeed we must
shift towards a new approach and that
would entail in my mind to combine the
efforts to have good governance in given
countries and to be really firm both on
the education side in order such as I
provide the workforce that is actually
needed in Africa for the future and then
also come with credits both for African
entrepreneurs and ours who dare shall I
say to invest in Africa who haven't got
the experience yet and in this regard I
think such initiatives with with SMEs if
we can combine that first the education
and vocational training and then
incoming investment then can contribute
to an added value that the cocoa is not
exported but becomes chocolate in Africa
the coffee beans become roasted coffee
in Africa and the cotton becomes
textiles in Africa to add value and then
give market access to us I think that is
the the proper way that we should be
adding for well I think I think it is
equally important to realize one factor
because inasmuch as as long as we
establish an European company in Africa
a lot of people will land a technology
involve a lot of people who have
experience from the people who came from
Europe for decades now and it's clearly
not working in some countries so what
needs to change I don't think it's not
working
it's like effort are not being made
because this thing is being more
rhetoric than actual because most of the
things that are being talked about on
this
partnership is something that is
happening or rhetoric thing because
things that I've been keeping they keep
on saying say in distance but there is
no practical thing on ground all right
mr. stroke organized the fact that
Europe has really helped Africa in area
of civil right good governance and
African countries are doing very well in
the area of good governance
accountability and as well as trying to
see that democracy is ensuring in our
system we'll get to that we'll get to
that in a second I just want to have a
look at what Steve rather Emmanuel macro
the president of France said on this
issue he says in a tweet Steve Jobs
father was a Syrian refugee it would
seem that nationality has nothing to do
with the ability to succeed if you think
that being a Nigerian means you can't
succeed then you want if you fight and
we do succeed you will be a role model
so I'm gonna come to you actually Mary
because you're really shaking your head
do you not believe in what the president
is saying no because it's not only a
question of will I think that sometimes
some companies are destroying the will
of people in African country if I take
for example oil in Nigeria you know that
the the most important part of the oil
in Nigeria is just exported in Europe to
be treated in Europe and resent to
Africa and there is no agreement to
prevent this situation and for example
what we asked for
as S&D is to have to thing is the trade
agreements the first thing is to have an
asymmetric situation with country like
Nigeria and to give them the opportunity
to have quotas to keep some raw
materials and to be sure that these raw
materials are preceded in the country
this is the first thing the second thing
that we have to ask for is to have due
diligence coming from big companies in
this country because it is not because
you are in big companies in this country
that you are respecting people or
climates so we have to have this due
diligence system in this car in for
these companies multinational when they
are in these countries so we have to
control them is mr.gao
quotas due dilligence sounds very
bureaucratic are you on board well no I
well I would say we from our side as far
as our companies and our international
companies are concerned we should really
put the appropriate pressure on them to
behave not only to understand us that we
have in our countries but also to obey
the laws that exist in the country okay
not too if you find not to give them
incentive it should be binding if you
have if you have a situation that our
some of our companies still think that
they can buy their their their permits
or that they can bribe officials that is
we have to overcome name and shame and
make it transparent this regard there
are initiatives and I published what you
pay or extractive industries
transparency initiatives that should
contribute to to a transparent way of of
doing business in Africa and I think mr.
Galan let me get to you due diligence
the European company are talking about I
totally disagree because most of the
European leaders most of the disk
companies European companies that are in
Africa
most of the corrupt Africa leaders get
their return in Europe from these
companies and this is how because we
can't just understand because most of
the money that is being stolen from
Africa by our leader is being stashed in
Europe and the European companies are
responsible for this and I don't think
there is any due diligence you are
talking about the most important thing
that we need to do in Africa is if we
want to depend this relationship is
there should be an open agreement and
disagreement between Africa and Europe
on certain aspect that leads to our dr.
Rada there are certain partnerships and
agreements which are on the table
awaiting signatures from certain
countries so it seems that Africa has
the opportunities but simply is not
taking them you know Africa doesn't have
that opportunity because those agreement
you are talking about this agreement
that we put on paper but most of the RIA
in the reality there are certain
conditions and European countries put
their programs up
or ahead of Africa we are not accident
of equal opportunity we are not
actionable equal partnership from Africa
what we are asking is simple that
whatever you are going to do we shall
have a mutual agreement there should be
a strategic plan for our development
taking into consideration or people
taking into consideration our because
there is no isn't it normal
basically I was going to come to you
isn't it normal that the European Union
puts its interests first and it's up to
the Africans to organize their interests
for example create a single market easy
so you are you are talking about
fairness and we are also talking about
win-win situation it means that both of
the parties have to gain something at
the end so I will I will come back maybe
to the EPS because I mention it and one
of the part or one of the benefits of
this disagreement is economic
partnership agreement sorry between
European countries and ACPs countries is
also this promotion of the shared values
it means that to have standards lever
standards to have good governance to
work together so that we have a unity
for sure it is a lot to do and it's not
only all countries who six ignite it I
know that Nigeria for instance is not in
it it's not saying it like Tanzania also
but Kenya which is also a good example
that's a they implemented so there are
some laws but now we have to also get
specific specifically to see why for
instance Nigeria is not yeah I think the
major thing is because of the
double-dealing who is double-dealing the
Europe because there should be that and
that is what is largely creating
mistrust if you are going to deal with
Africa this deal with Africa as an
entity okay happy to accept an African
agenda on an African free-trade area and
also to adapt our inner powers our
regional agreements to what you plan
because I think it's we have profited as
Europeans amongst our trading
amongst ourselves that is has made us
strong and wealthy and I would wish that
this African agenda to have an
free-trade area into Africa that that is
being supported from our side and one
more thing if they want know if they if
Africa wants to protect itself from us
they could already prior to having their
own integration inside they could erase
setup and pan-african customs tariffs
that applies to all of Africa
European and American or an Asian
imports that would protect Africa
efficiently and we could not work one
against the other
if that if they were in agreement with
themselves in this regard for serene
misery no seems unhappy no in fact in
the Eco s region for example they are
working on the internal market for this
region and what Europe did is because of
Nigeria blocking and wine Egeria is
blocking this epass it's just because
they said they want to protect the
infant industry and it's normal it is
the way to have industry in your country
is for a moment to protect them and
after to open your country and Nigeria
is asking for this and Europe say no and
what Europe did is just going to Ghana
and going to Cote d'Ivoire and saying if
Nigeria say no we are dealing with you
separately and so we are destroying the
internal internal market of Africa and
if you see for example with the all the
agreements that we have between Africa
and Europe for a long time ago we don't
have this increasing of exchange between
Africa and Europe so what do you expect
what do you want the next European
Parliament and quickly to do in that
respect what is important is really not
to be appropriate on this and to support
the internal market of Africa because I
think is for SMEs is more important to
have this internal internal market that
to have the market with Europe and
second thing is to have a path that
respects what African countries are
asking for for their development for
people living in Africa not for
multinationals that are coming from
Europe
in Africa that is all step by step
implemented as a long time scale there
are transitional times and there must be
an effort also also to integrate amongst
themselves Africa must tear down its
internal borders simply to become better
in trade and in and and in in investment
and in creating jobs so Terada is this
easier said than done I mean you did say
that Europe is double-dealing dealing
with echo as separately and you want
them to deal with an African equal
opportunity is not being given because
we recognize the fact that Africa and
Europe are not equal because Africa has
a population of about 1/4 and TB and
Europe has a population of about over
500 million and when you look at our GDP
Europe has a GDP of over 17 trillion
dollars and in Africa you find a GDP of
less than 3 trillion and now that you're
talking about unity excuse me let's give
us more opportunity when it comes to
even border look at it the opportunity
European man has to go to Africa is
quite higher than the opportunity and
Africa has to come to Europe because
when you go to the embassies you see the
kind of maltreatment the European
embassies were given to offer you will
get to migration in just a second the
question you talked about figures and
the EU being able to trade in huge
quantities but the EU is also trading
with each other
intra EU trade is at 70% and intra
Africa trade is at 16% we are not
trading with each other so the question
is why do we expect trade with the EU to
be better if we can handle it ourselves
you know you have to understand one
simple thing we are trading in order for
us to gain and we gain more when we
trade from this perspective but the most
important thing for us to understand and
even for Europe to understand there is
an effect the property level in Africa
has effect on Europe because of the
proximity the closest point approach the
committee in terms of geopolitical area
is only at
miles between Europe and Africa so there
are replication if there is problem in
Nigeria if that is probably her one day
if there is problem in Somalia there is
embarrass them in Europe so what we are
trying to do is give us equal
opportunity try to give us understand
our interest and so that our prosperity
has a very huge effect at the end you
are preventing you from cooperating
closer with each other if you have a
customs union in Eastern Africa we are
not preventing that but if there are
hiccups we are happy to to support
because we've got experience in this
regard more integration regional
integration in Africa and finally a Penn
Continental free-trade area okay that is
the objective and I want to now look at
the impact of some of these
interconnections that dr. Rada was
talking about free movement of persons
you've heard him say here that it can be
humiliating sometimes for an African to
try and gain access to Europe even when
they are doing it regularly but what
happens when it's irregular the issue of
migration has been on hot-button issue
for both Africa and Europe and here's
why migration one of the toughest
challenges facing Europe the issue of
refugee resettlement deeply divides the
European Union the EU has failed to rein
in political infighting among its
members it's impossible to let everybody
to cross the Schengen borders not in a
way which is clearly clarified
the EU continues to depend on deals with
third countries like Turkey because it
has not come up with a solution for
sharing the burden that is one of the
reasons behind Europe's new top priority
helping Africa to get on its feet in
order to curb the flow of migrants boost
development aid and oblige African
leaders to deal with his citizens in a
way that African youth has a chance this
means both public investment and private
investment is no previous Europe can't
afford Africa to be in bad shape as
migration issue continues to give rise
to right wing and anti-european populist
movements finally the EU will get back
to defend its borders and the right for
security of its European citizens in
addition tanea way the European Union
and Africa remain under pressure how can
they shape their common future
you know isn't the migration crisis the
best thing that could have happened to
Africa in the last year's because it put
it finally on the map in European
discussions the Europeans have to do
something now first of all for all
people concerned in this migration it's
a tragedy because everybody in principle
wants to stay at home and have a good
living there so the fact that people are
leaving is out of desperation mostly and
not out of adventurism or even what I'm
talking about the political level yeah
yes I've never really talked about
Africa before the migration crisis in
this way that's well I wouldn't go so
far but I think indeed we have to deal
with Africa in a different way and it's
good that we do not limit our
discussions on this migration issue
which is an important one
but that we see it in a long-term
perspective and that we discuss about
the issues like economy that we had in
in the previous panel but I think we
could as Europeans assume our
responsibilities of course in addressing
it in a way that of course we cannot
take every person that is in need into
Europe but we should categorize we
should see who is personally persecuted
as a political asylum seeker who is
under the Geneva Conventions as a war
refugee and who comes for purely
economic reasons and in this field I
think we have to open a slight door for
legal migration in order to focus the
people on the legal opportunity we seems
to think we need more than just a slight
or a slight opening for sure so for your
question was also if this migration also
opened the door and said that now it
should be an in in the agenda and for
sure as you said with mrs. Merkel it's
not that only till 2015 the question of
Africa is now but I can say that now we
are moving from this policy of
development aid to something else with
the promoting with private sector and
doing of searching other ways to to
solve this problem and now I can really
say that on the agenda of the EU or the
agenda of the the the German government
the private sector is really on the
agenda it is like a way to put also
opportunity to create opportunity in
Africa to deal with immigration because
as I said nobody wants to go to build to
to to Europe only because it's it's it's
fine alright so I want to continue this
arena because we're talking about
policies that started in 2015 but we
wait too long to start having
conversations conversation between
Europe and Africa I think that we have
to have the awareness that we need as
European more Africa that Africa needs
Europe and this is really important
because the only thing that we see is
just seeing these poor people living
Africa coming to Europe but you know the
more the most important mobility in
Africa is in Africa within Africa
between different countries in Africa
and we are just the end of the process
but this is the most important mobility
situation is in Africa and if we are not
aware of the fact that we need Africa
and we spoke about material raw
materials but also market we are just in
a wrong way of thinking Africa and so
for me it's important to have two things
the first is the legal way for mobility
I don't know what you agree with mr.
Gallow there I don't speak about
migration because you know when you have
young students comment from Africa
coming in Europe to the University what
they want to do is to go back to Africa
and to make businesses and to have for
example health care but talking about it
we're talking about irregular migration
those who are coming here from pressure
economic or otherwise so first thing is
the mobility and I think that Europe was
an open Europe and for the moment we are
a closed Europe we don't want to have
foreigners in Europe this is the first
thing and we have to reopen Europe for
African people not only for stew
but also for some workers and this
relationship with Africa the second
thing is humanitarian situation and we
as Europe but all the continent will
have humanitarian citizen asking for
protection and this is the way we have
to to put an end to these people and to
say you are welcoming out and this is
something else but we don't have to
mixed this to situation we have to make
our duty on humanitarian help right
thing that are the right-wing populist
seem to mix that I mean the dissension
is very important yeah and before we
come over to you mr. gala dr. Arata
are you following what the run-up to the
European elections where a lot of
right-wing populist that are making
their living off of the topic of
migration are poised to make significant
gains and what do you think about that I
think before we get to that we have to
understand the fact that why I Africans
migrate into Europe because we have an
economic situation in Africa that needs
to be addressed by our early which we
talked about that is extensive advanced
yes doctor let me that's very important
to me
let tell me how you feel about the
possibility of people of parties gaining
significant votes in the European
elections because they almost
exclusively campaign on the topic of
migration yeah because that is a major
thing that is affecting Europe because
there is a new trend all over the wall
of national addition if countries are
becoming more national countries are
becoming more soft recognized doing
things on their own ways and that is why
you see that British ones who go out of
Europe and you see a lot of other
countries wanting to be and why he that
that Dayton has manifested itself also a
being the United State you can see the
era of nationalization is springing off
and even in Africa you see a lot of
elections have taken place and the
government where the opposition
opposition parties were taking over
governments we
cause people need a new lease of life
people need a new life new government
people have hope and they are looking
for where those hoops will come from and
these are the kind of things we are
looking for from Europe and it is very
important for the relationship between
Africa and Europe but the most important
thing let's do it with mutual agreement
remove and Europe needs to move from
conditionality and sanctions and try to
focus more on understanding agreement
this agreement which are mutually
understandable mr. garlotte might
disagree with that
unconditionally well I mean the first
the responsibility for the well-being of
African citizens and we had former
president / Sandra here some years ago
he said who is responsible for the
unemployed youth in Africa first of all
it's us Africans yes if you your rulers
assume their responsibilities first I'm
very happy to support all those who
really undertake efforts to improve this
it is yes and he has never done any
significant change to the life of the
people of messenger's policies
specifically yeah I mean I guess what
mr. galley is trying to say that
Africans should ideally be responsible
for African problems of course and no
and and I'm as I said very much I am
very much prepared to assist an African
agenda to improve this situation and
when it comes to to the migration issues
unfortunately for the populists s-- this
is low-hanging fruit for their campaign
but we will be sure if there were not
the African migrants they would find
national minorities and if that were not
them they would find others to put
people against each other so that is
that is the problem so it's it's for
them it doesn't matter who is better but
unfortunately migrants are the the
lowest hanging fruit we talked about
African and European problems right now
ah yes
so migration people are coming from
Africa okay is that an African problem
so I think that's what you're thinking
of talking about so why nation that is
nationalism or populism I think it's
also because we said that Africa is the
the neighbours of Europe and Europe and
Europe is very close to Africa but they
don't know each other actually and I
think that the the media they also have
the part of their responsibilities the
ways I put on this issue when this
migration flow was there and it puts
also like as Maria said it's not that
the first destination was Europe it was
weaving Africa and then in Europe but I
think that we strength this some this
situation so far that everybody thinks
wow they are all coming to my country we
have to do something we have to close
the borders and stuff so I think that
first of all we really have to to know
each other and the Europe and Europe
have to know what is Africa now because
actually we need it why because you see
in Africa there is the most young people
and this those people are not people
that is they're very very well educated
and they have a lot to impart to the
love to give also we should come to that
positive part in just a second I would
like to wrap up the part who's to blame
actually because there's always a lot of
blame game between Africa and the
European Union with a tweet from the
Rwandan president Paul Kagame if who's
somebody who doesn't really mince his
words very clear tweets always and he
tweeted if you look at history of this
migration for a long time Europe was
inciting inviting people to go to Europe
the message was your countries of Africa
are governed badly and you should come
to us that message you heard yeah no I
think I think Africa generally needs a
Europe while we need it because the
relationship is so emotional why is it
emotional is because it's dated back
since colonialism
name so and we need Europe to help
Africa to block the issue of Africa on
the block itself we need to be natured
they need to carry us hold our hands try
to see how they can help us to the blow
in terms of good governance they should
be encouraged they should be encouraged
illicit funds from Africa into Europe
they should as much as possible try to
depart with these funds back to Africa
because there is a lot especially in
Nigeria now there are a lot of huge
corrupt money in Europe that are
touching European bonds that European
countries refuse to repatriate those
money back to Africa we need a HUD
holding Europe need to hold Africa
Europe need to support Africa and we
need to have a mutual understanding
between us do you agree with this does
Africa need hand-holding
we have the common future the two
important reasons for migration massive
migration inside Africa and also at
South Africa are whoa
instability lack of peace in some
countries and the second one is the
climate change these are the most
important reason for migration even more
than economic situation even more than
economics in the daily life if we have
daily life no job if you if you speak
about massive migration displaced people
its peace lack of peace and climate
change and we are we have a part of
responsibility together on this on the
climate change so we have to work
together on this help Africa to go to
the transition for the climate change
and also help Africa to go to democratic
way of governance in their country and
peace so I think that we need together
it's not because Africa needs Europe we
need together to go in this path of
climate change and peace so together to
fight climate change one example but
we've heard from miss angry already that
she thought there might be a little
potential for something going beyond
there and I'd like to put that question
that's part of that to mr. gala isn't
Africa with all those young people who
want to work who want to learn and the
aging Europe the perfect partner for the
future yes I would I would definitely
agree I mean this is a neighboring
continent with this huge potential and
that has to be put in a system that
really this potential can be realized
and it starts with with the issues that
we address before good governance and
investment these are encouraging signs
there I see I see more and more African
intellectuals and youth and civil
society in many countries that address
these issues and that get government's
under threat I mean we've seen it for 20
years in Zimbabwe as one example
unfortunately the regime was stronger
still and you can go through many
countries where long sitting presidents
think that they have a future I think
actually they don't but they the the
people are I think in in a in a in a
pole position to trigger a change and if
if that goes ahead I think we should
stand by and actively pursue this
African agenda to to to get the
development done I think there is enough
intelligence and enough will amongst
civil society and the young people in
Europe and in Africa and we should come
in and support that so Bienvenue we've
been talking about boundless potential a
young population getting even younger
but at what point do we realize this
potential is it an infinite state of
being so this potential is there and
because of the lack of opportunities
maybe in their countries it is not
possible to x22 to take them and to
explore this opportunity and this young
so the problem now or the question now
is how to to deal with the city
situation and we talk about vocational
trainings and what you is implementing
for that so Germany is very active and
I'm impossible but is it working we
we'll come back to that and we say that
on the European level you have this
you're mobilized SMEs for instance or
this vocational training for
entrepreneurs so we really have to
encourage those majors to to to just
build these people is it working
I mean it's not that that is not a lot
we have to make a lot of them so that it
can work I have maybe an example in the
the town of senegal dakar there is a
small slum it is called Baraka and in
this town there is about 2,000 people
they are living there and what did the
German SM is because it is really a
private things they said we have to
transform this area two steps efficient
City so that they at the end can be
self-sufficient and the young people can
have a future and what what what
happened some enterprises left camps
came to the big companies from for the
bakery area they come there and they
just give the know-how how to make
bakery and a lot of SMEs were part of it
and they are now building a new town
from this to Islam to a new one and this
is a practical right a practical example
that's also positive and that concludes
our conversation right here at least for
now we're entering what max actually
believes is the most fun part of this
conversation but he also wanted me that
his German so okay let's go quick fire
around max doing it to the first one
yes we have actually you're allowed only
to say one word as an answer to what I'm
going to do now usually weren't we will
start over here and we'll call clockwise
okay
so I start with MS angry and the
question is what are you looking for
what are you looking at in the outcome
of the European elections so I one word
inclusion inclusion
reason prevails please invest in Africa
I'm sorry
invest in Africa investment solidarity
I'll give you a little bit more leeway
for my question please answer the
following sentence Europe and Africa are
partners depending on each other
the the okay we'll give you time five
seconds equal now you have to go though
no I think no right word is one word we
have 20 seconds left partners partners
okay and I think that's a fantastic way
to conclude this discussion it ended
rather positively you wouldn't have
thought that at the beginning of this
discussion with a lot of tension but we
thank you both we thank you all for your
time yeah thanks for being here of
course stick around with DW for
extensive coverage of the European
elections in May
[Music]
you